[Music]
lumpam you're headlining the selena
quintanilla fiesta de la Flor first of
all what does that mean to you that is
such an amazing moment
I mean it's um it was a pretty surreal
thing when a bee was trying to get a
hold of me on the phone I mean that's
one of her that's her brother one but
one of the people who was closest to her
toured the world with her and kind of
created everything with her her family
and so for them to reach out to me and
asked me to headline a festival that is
in her honor to celebrate everything
that she's done and kind of that bridge
that she started for people and to be
able to be one of those pioneering
artists to help finish that bridge is
incredible and you know she she was the
the epitome of everything that I needed
growing up that that Spanglish life a
little bit of English a little bit of
Spanish you don't have to choose exactly
I was saying I'm the two hundred percent
100% I think I just as much as I am 100
percent American I shouldn't have to
divide myself to live in in both worlds
so the festival will be a lot of fun
what was the song that maybe really kind
of first inspired you Oh Beatty Beatty
bomb bombs oh my god II can sing that
bitty bitty long mom
you know it's catchy
[Music]